one child in 10 around the world is
forced into work but progress on
eliminating child labour has stalled the
un says poverty and rising living costs
could create millions more child
labourers so what will it take to bring
that to an end this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
every day an estimated 160 million
children are forced to work often in
dangerous conditions some are as young
as five years old this year's united
nations world day against child labour
is calling for better social protections
so parents aren't forced to send their
youngsters to work these include free
education
child care and child support payments
it's one of six points of action agreed
last month at a lab international labour
organization conference in south africa
delegates were told that another nine
million children could be pushed into
the workforce by the end of the year
one rescued child worker from india
explained how access to education helped
end child labour in her village
i am the first girl to complete class 12
exams in my community just like right
now there is no child doing labor in my
village there should be no child labour
in any part of the world i want to ask
you a question we kids don't have the
authority to cast a vote so should we
have the authority to do child labour is
it the children's fault that we are born
in a small village so we don't have the
right to a childhood with freedom we
also want freedom we also want the right
to education
but in many countries children have no
choice but to earn a living that's a
growing concern as high inflation pushes
up the cost of food energy and housing
worldwide
i am the eldest in the family and so i'm
in charge of supporting my sisters and
brother and helping my mother find food
in the morning i do the chores then i
come to work to search for gold if we
find something i buy the food then i
make the meal school is not an option
for me or any of the children
here what forced me to work is a
situation my father is unwell and can't
work anymore and i only have one brother
working from time to time during the
month
well children across the globe are
routinely engaged in paid and unpaid
forms of work so what actually
constitutes child labour well
international law classifies children as
child labourers when they carry out any
work whilst under 13 years of age
18 is the minimum age for carrying out
work considered harmful long-term
whether physically emotionally or
mentally
although child labour can increase a
household's income in the long term it
perpetuates household poverty the more
child work because in the economy the
lower their wages the latest estimates
suggest child labour is increasing
amongst children age 5 to 11. there are
now at least 16.8 million more child
labourers than in 2016.
40 percent of them carry out dangerous
work
[Music]
let's bring in our guests now and in new
delhi we have shanta sinha founder of mv
foundation that's a charity working on
ending child labour in new york stephen
blight global senior child protection
adviser at the un's children's agency
unicef and in dhaka in bangladesh nazma
akhtar the
foundation and a former child worker in
the garment industry a very warm welcome
to all of you
shanta if i could start with you just to
give us a bit more of a broader idea as
to what child labour actually means
is it only when a child is working
instead of going to school or does it
include children who might say work in a
family shop after school or help
periodically with the harvest what does
it actually involve
um
i i would start by saying that child
labor
should be defined as children out of
school you know
and
also say that if a child is not
attending school then the child is in
some form of work or the other
and even if she's not in some form of
work today she's going to be only part
of an unskilled labor force so i would
define child labour as every child of
the school and if the child is in school
i should still think that the child
before and after school hours should not
be working which is a peril to her
attending school and participating in
school as an equal citizen in fact i
take a very strong stamp on the matter
saying that even before and after school
hours children from marginalized
impoverished
community
should have the leisure and childhood
and should be able to
build their capacities to their full
fullest potential
nasma you yourself were a child labourer
tell us what you did and why you did it
thank you
why i did it because my family
is very poor and i need to support my
family that is why i started to work in
the factory when age of 11
and i work like
10 to 14 hours in a day and it's not
that
very good journey or very interesting
things for us
and also you know the one of the
challenges what feeds because my mother
also working in the factory
and she's not earning much more than me
so that is also one of the issues
because the minimum living wage is
needed for the
adults and parents because that is why
sometimes they are demotivated also and
also what is uh we are facing in my
country and also rest of the country
because children are mostly do the very
unique kind of work if i'm going to the
very luxury jewellery or luxury dress
the embroidery and also very
hazardous dangerous work children are
their finger is very much
usable and also the children when you
shout if you yelling they are scared
then they can do more work so this kind
of uh seems to uh
going on and abuse are
treated and
there is no
monitoring there is no
proper good system for the things and we
don't have over action plan so it's a
very uh difficult also the when the
family is not getting proper wages and
benefited and social protection
insurance policy a lot of issues are
addressing and also another issue is the
child labor is increasing because most
of the women's who are working no child
care no day care center although law is
uh require an
education adequate and sufficient care
must be for the women's workers who are
working so this is also one of the
challenge that they send their children
and countryside living in the village
and two months babies are separate from
the parents so so many issues and also
you know mostly the informal sector
so-called informal sector where the
legally is not require a
job contract and the things so there is
a woman and children's are abused
and
worker doesn't have any recognition and
then a lot of hazardous like a workshop
the transportation factory
uh they're working and
that's that is one of the issues is very
much difficult for me just just just
briefly uh
you started at age 11 so that means you
left school at age 11.
were you ever able to return again to
school
no because i didn't go back to or return
to school because i work in the factory
like uh more than eight years and then i
realized because how i deprived from the
education how i deprive my rights as a
citizen as a fundamental as a child so
that is why when i work in the factory
when i lost my job i was union organizer
and i have lot of issue and then i
decided i we should do something for
ourselves and we should do something
more on freedom of association freedom
of access
expression and how do we
reduce this kind of exploitation child
labor and i also a lot of um
speak on the child labor issue when i
was young until now and trying to be uh
our foundation we are trying to educate
our
workers i certainly want to come back to
you and get more of an idea of the
success of your work so far but just for
the moment i want to uh bring stephen
into the discussion i think nasm has
very clearly showed us
some of the push factors that push
children into labor and also how that
can have a negative effect on the child
and the family because the children
don't get the education but stephen can
you give us more of an idea of where we
see these cases of child labour and what
are the factors that lead to massive
pockets of them in certain parts of the
world
yeah thanks for that and um i mean one
thing to keep in mind is over the last
few decades there's been a
you know a trend downwards in terms of
prevalence of um
child labor so there has been progress
that's been made but where that progress
has stalled what we've been pinpointing
is um firstly in
sub-saharan africa
and uh
secondly the um agricultural sector
okay so about you know the 160 million
out of out of or in child labor about 86
million of those are in uh sub-saharan
africa
and 70 of those in child labor are in uh
in
agriculture
why do you think that is
the um
well in terms of the um regional trends
there's a there's a number of um factors
that sort of come together in
sub-saharan africa one is relatively
high level of poverty
in sub-saharan africa
the
level of economic informality which
means that the workplaces are less
regulated
social protection systems
are
relatively weaker in many of the
countries in that continent
education
access to free and quality education is
weaker
we also have um
uh
larger growth in the younger
age population in sub-saharan africa and
i think you mentioned before we're
seeing a big growth in the 5 to 11 year
olds in
child labor
and then finally
i think
issues of state fragility
crisis conflict
situations so i mean all regions of the
world have these um that contribute to
child labor but i think there might be a
greater convergence in uh sub-saharan
africa certainly when it um you know
concerns high levels of smallholder
agriculture okay i also do want to
return to that point in just a moment
but just before we do shanta i want to
get an idea from you whether you saw a
similar trend there in india the numbers
of child labourers declining stalling
after 2016 and whether you were seeing
rising numbers in agriculture as well
you know
it's entirely true that you know the
last ticket there has been positive
results about child labor decreasing
in india and
that has got to do with the
laws on free and compulsory education
and children going to schools and a huge
civil society as well as state action on
the matter but i should think that the
combat situation has
pushed the clock back and children are
again back in farms
back in
cotton farms back in coal mines back in
embroidery and everywhere so in a way i
would think that
there is an exacerbation of equality
inequality
and apparel to girls and their education
and more and more number of children are
going back into work
i should try to say here just one point
that normally one would say that all
this is happening because children are
poor i think all this is happening
because there is state complacency and
state in action there is just not enough
infrastructure to protect children and
even the state begins to argue the
children are working because they are
poor i think we will have to somewhere
abandon the poverty argument more than
poverty i think it is a poverty argument
that makes children work they are source
of cheap labor they can be exploited and
forced to work for long hours
in fact we have seen in the work that we
did that when we did bring children from
out of work into schools the wages for
women went up at least five times
protection systems began to function
schools began to function in fact child
labour caused poverty it depressed wages
it brought in low quality of life in the
family and we should stop arguing that
children are
poor and so they have to work children
have rights they are entitlement holders
they are not responsible for their
poverty you and me are responsible and
the state is even more responsible and
they have to take care of children
justice is what we should talk about
inequality and argument for equality is
what we have to talk about finally we
cannot anymore do the analysis of why
child labour i think we have to learn
from positive experiences and talk about
how to bring children to school i think
the question how is so so important
and we will get on to that in just a
moment first i want to check with nasma
whether you agree uh with shantha that
it is state inaction that is the reason
the main driver of these high high
numbers of child labourers that we're
seeing and is this the case that you're
saying in bangladesh
yes
i am totally agree with that
what she said also the cheap labor and
what i really mentioned uh earlier that
the parents need to be decent wages and
decent working condition that is also
one of the issues and also uh pro
because
the quality of education and education
is not
properly happen but recently the
bangladesh government is ready for ilo
convention 138
and just
in last march but it's not only the
ratification but they need to be also
action plan how they have to uh function
above this ratification even our country
the law said if you're below a's uh
workers you need to get five hours work
and rest of the hour for the education
and recreation but nobody's follow is
and bother so that is why state has a
lot of responsibility the
food and education and social protection
and children's whatever growth all kind
of things are very much absent for
country like bangladesh
back in 2015 world leaders committed to
ending all forms of child labour by 2025
that's three years away why have they
not done it
you know it's it's as um as shanta for
example mentioned i mean um this is a
rights issue there's been a number of
international treaties there's been the
um two ilo treaties that i think were
referenced there's a convention on the
rights of the child
as well and um and so any child and
labor is uh is not tolerable and we all
have an obligation to uh to bring it to
an end
um
progress has been made
um since 2015 as mentioned but it is uh
stalled and um one of the areas one of
the factors i think we have to look at
is the um the impact of uh covert 19
which has um you know as well as um
increasing poverty it has um
um
as well
um you know kids stop going to school as
schools were closed and um that brought
more and more of them back into family
agriculture as families
and other family occupations as you know
parents didn't have the child care and
there was no alternative other than uh
than work so that's been a big
setback to our uh to our efforts
i think to um
to
you know get get back on uh on track
um
um you know in the current context i
mean you really really need to double
down on this
social protection element making sure
that uh that poor families get the
income support necessary to get um so
their kids don't resort to working and
then stepping up the um
work to get kids back into school and to
um keep them in schools we don't want to
see
an outcome of the covert 19 crisis of
being a big increase in child labor
shantha as you said we need to talk
about what needs to be done and this is
one um big theme of this year's un day
for child labor
do you feel though that it is a priority
for governments that they have taken
this on board and they're going to
create this social protection for people
with a real desire to end child labour
uh i do hope
it can actually happen but so far one
has not seen uh signs of where children
have become centrality of policy making
force covered during cohen of course
they were totally lost and not even
spoken about after covert there is a lot
of noise by the civil society and the
u.n agencies also but then it has not
been internalized by the
within the countries i think there is
such a big need for greater doubling the
investments uh to get children back into
school after covert you know and also
reassuring them telling them that not
all is lost your dreams and aspirations
for higher education cannot be just
drizzled away that we will bring you
back to school that kind of
voice is so important from the
establishment that has not come as yet i
think it is so important to have both a
centralized movement and a noise and
saying that look we care for you get
back to schools and then making the
schools ready for the loss of education
making the schools ready for
through bridge courses
through accelerated learning through
also talking to children about what they
went through during the comic times
somewhere telling them we are there for
you and we know you went through a lot
of difficulties tell us what you did and
contact to connect with the poor
children is so important nothing of that
sort has so far happened i'm not sure if
it's happened in other countries but you
know
generally when one reads the uh
literature of the matter it seems there
are zoom conferences but then actual
action on the ground is is bounty
exactly stephen i just want to bring
bring you in at this point because i
want to know if we do have any positive
examples of where this has happened and
where it has worked
yeah that was i mean you mentioned um
the the durbin call to auction the
recent conference that took place and um
you know given um you know
accepting the points that conferences
don't uh solve problems but they do um
serve a couple of important uh functions
one is to share those experiences and uh
and good practices and then to um
you know reforge that that um that
government commitment so we've seen a
number of positive um
examples
from around the world um
where um
schools for example undertook outreach
programs to get those kids who were
at risk of going into labor back into
school and keeping them there
we've seen
a big um in a number of countries a big
expansion of uh social protection
measures um
cash grants for children with that for
families with children um that were i
think um accelerated um during the um
the covert 19 pandemic as a as a
as a response and we're also seeing um
we have to keep in mind that uh there's
also a supply chain right and many of
the products that children are engaged
in producing end up in um
you know in in consumer
societies and responsible
businesses need to have some
responsibility to look at their supply
chains
you know back to where the raw materials
are sourced absolutely and that just
brings me on to the last point that i
want to make to
nasa because um we are running nasm
sorry we are running a little bit out of
time but
bangladesh is a country that's got a
large number of multinationals working
in it in the garment industry how much
of this is an issue that those
multinational companies should be taking
on board as well as the governments of
the country themselves
uh
thank you in bangladesh and the
ready-made garments sector in the supply
chain
used to be since 90 or
early 20 used to be the child labor was
the threat and 30 percent children was
working since 90 but after gradually a
lot of uh international campaign and
lobby and fighting for the
children abusing in the clothing
industry so we don't have that tricks in
the garment sector like a child labor
but we have below 18 like 14 16 years
old workers are working so but
we are also exporting other
goods and other issue agriculture
fisheries local market
there is a lot of children are using and
exploitation because you know that
system we do have to leave it there
apologies we have run out of time for
this discussion it's a shame it's a very
interesting discussion indeed uh but for
the moment thank you very much to our
guests shanthas seen her
stephen blight and nasma actor for
joining us
and thank you two for watching you can
see this program again anytime by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com forward slash aj inside
story you can also join the conversation
on twitter our handle is at aj inside
story from me laura kyle and the whole
team here in doha bye for now
[Music]